eight the whole head all right guys you
read the title you clicked on this video
you and I both just want to see people
eat some spiders
I was recently scrolling through Amazon
and I was in the gourmet food section
and I found edible dehydrated boiled
tarantulas Amazon you've got some cool
[ __ ] so obviously I ordered it I've told
my friends that they're gonna be trying
out gourmet foods from Amazon I haven't
told them that gourmet means spider
today we'll be trying gourmet food from
Amazon a lot of weird stuff on Amazon
for Ana's and snakes are we getting
gourmet piranhas are we getting gourmet
chocolate from Amazon what's the
weirdest thing you've ever eaten rabbit
there's a thing in the South called
Rocky Mountain Oysters it's just fried
testicles I'm not for myself
I bet we're gonna eat bugs today
chocolate-covered bugs how's the one in
done with bugs I know I'm the gourmet
stuff man bringing I would bring it um
drugs because you put it in this fancy
dish does not make it gourmet it's a
gourmet candy from Amazon it's probably
what is this so this is a zebra tree and
the ingredients are zebra tarantula in
salt once opened consumed immediately is
this thing like in there right now
kids are like shaking right one
tarantula I gotta get in the tree house
this that's crazy wow that's so there's
some lame you made here Oh
so bad
[Music]
there's too much hair on it bro
this spider had a family spider had a
light spider had a 401k this spider had
a Roth IRA this spider had a job one day
away from retiring I'm gonna strip it
out cuz I'm like eating a tarantula
that's crazy this is like colic bonnet
that's like packing sunflower seeds it
tastes just like a lightly salted place
[ __ ] I'm curious to know how the head
tastes so uh how does it taste
next pair of people were crunchy I
regret that so much I can say now that
I've eaten spider King Barack Obama say
that the crazy thing about it is that it
tastes fishy but then there's a crunch
I'm in the middle is Harry now I just
want to try and be free I want it yeah I
want to try now that I've done the worst
tarantula you could possibly eat I want
to eat a real fat one you know what Eric
just to be a good sport I'm gonna I'm
gonna eat the body of this tarantula
[Music]
[Music]
watching it's on Amazon so there's one
firefighter
[Music]